hi and welcome to my molecular biology
playlist today we are going to talk
about
nucleosome remodeling complex now it's a
very important topic in molecular
biology and let's see what nucleosome
remodeling is all about we know inside
the cell the nucleus is the hub of all
kind of gene expression transcription
and also our chromatin resides inside
the nucleus so let's dive inside the
nucleus to see what happens now inside
the nucleus there are genes but we
cannot imagine the genes in a isolated
DNA format we have to understand the
gene the genes are actually in format of
a chromatin right so gene is actually a
segment of a chromatin histones are also
there along with the DNA and they're
packed in certain fashion depending upon
the time of cell cycle that is why we
cannot imagine a gene which is isolated
let's imagine a gene which is one kilo
base pair long and at least it would
have five nucleosome right so the DNA
which is encoding that gene would be
wrapping around five such nucleosome and
let's say at a particular context at a
particular given point of time that gene
has to be transcribed and imagine how
hard that process would be first the
transcription initiation site or the
promoter site need to be unwrapped and
need to be accessible to RNA polymerase
an initial transcriptional machinery and
not only that the RNA polymerase need to
travel all along the body of the gene
while then histones are bound to it so
it need to be loosen up a little bit
such that these movement can happen and
only then the transcription can take
place not only transcription imagine
there is a DNA damage and in order for
the damage to be repaired the repair
machinery need to be recruited to the
DNA but the DNA is not isolated right
DNA is wrapped around these new
to use ohm course that is why it is
super difficult for the cell to recruit
such machinery and give rise to
transcription or repairing the DNA now
in order to get rid of this kind of
problem cell has a different machinery
which can change the configuration or
the architecture of the chromatin in
space and time and these kind of
complexes are known as nucleosome
remodelling complexes so the biggest
question is how the compaction of the
chromatin is loosened up and that give
rise to gene expression or many other
kind of biological functions so we know
that one possible idea is to modify the
histone tails like methylation as a
dilation or phosphorylation etc all this
kind of modification dictates that how
tightly DNA would be wrapped around the
histone octamer core and about that I
have a separate video and which is given
at the end of this video the link is
given at the end of this video now there
are two ways by which the nucleosome can
loosen up and the DNA can be accessible
while wrapped around the nucleosome one
is definitely the histone modification
but there are other ways they are like
bromodomain containing proteins
chromosome and continuing proteins and
complex proteins which recognize these
kind of modifications and that is read
as a bar code which is further give rise
to a change which leads to accessible
chromatin but there are other complexes
such as nucleosome remodelling complexes
which are ATP driven because nucleosome
remodeling or chromatin landscape
changing it's not a easy job
so it requires ATP and lot of energy and
it is quite expensive process in terms
of thermodynamics now the nucleosome
remodeling complex hydrolyzes ATP
to perform this kind of nucleosome
reorient ring work now we should ask
that what kind of changes in terms of
chromosome architecture does have is
evoked due to the nucleosome remodeling
complexes there it turns out that there
could be different type of changes and
in this video we would look at all of
them one by one so one common thing is
like all of these nucleosome remodeling
complex use ATP hydrolysis as a fuel for
this kind of dramatic changes first type
of change is sliding of the nucleosome
and changing the space between the
nucleosome let's say the nucleosomes are
oriented like this and due to for gene
expression you need these nucleosome to
be slided around so the nucleosome
remodeling complex binds to the
particular region and then with the ATP
hydrolysis it leads to change in the
spacing between the nucleosomes now you
can understand before and after the
nucleosome remodeling complex engagement
there is a change of inter nuclear
thermal space right and that has a lot
of meaning imagine that there is a
particular region marked in red here
this is the transcription start site and
the RNA polymerase need to be bound in
that particular region but in a compact
situation the RNA polymerase is repelled
away because the DNA is so tightly
wrapped around the histone it is not
accessible anymore but nucleosome
remodelling complex let's just slide the
histones octamer a little bit and as a
result the inaccessible site now become
accessible for the RNA polymerase to
bind and as a result the transcription
can start there are other kind of
changes evoked by nucleosome remodeling
complexes such as the histones or
histone octamer
which is rapid which is wrapped around
the DNA can be evicted by the nucleosome
remodeling complex it can totally allow
the release of a nucleosome core and
thereby free up the DNA for interacting
with other DNA binding proteins or
repair machineries this is one kind of
mechanism that nucleosome use histone
eviction now the new sites which are
accessible can bind to transcription
factor may be other modification enzymes
or maybe a DNA repair machinery and that
lead to transcription and that's how the
transcription dynamics is changing
inside the cell third mechanism involves
the replacement of the histone with a
different variant of histone for example
the genes which are highly transcribed
or the genes which are actively
transcribed in those genes the histone
h3 is replaced by h3 point 3 which is a
histone variant found in actively
transcribed genes and this is done by
several different kind of nucleosome
remodelling complexes now let's say
there is a double-stranded DNA break and
in order to repair this double stranded
DNA break the repair machinery need to
be recruited but it is hard for the
repair machinery to be recruited while
it is in the compact form
now what nucleosome remodelling complex
does is make it more accessible and
loosen it up such that the repair
machinery can be recruited and the
double-stranded DNA break can be
repaired and one of the common way by
which nucleosome remodelling complex
does this is by recruiting a histone
variant called h2ax and it is recruited
when damage sensing kinase is
phosphorylate specific histones and
these lead to recruitment of repair
machinery and that helps in
the damage okay let's talk about the
several kind of nucleosome remodeling
complexes that work hand-in-hand inside
the cell
now first family is swi/snf and this is
pretty much common in East human and
Drosophila and it is well conserved and
about this particular nucleosome
remodeling complex I have a separate
video other than these there are is w1
complex there is Ino 8t complex there is
MI 2 CH D family complexes and each of
these complexes has some qumola
commonality in terms of their
functioning but some unique properties
in terms of their functioning as well so
the biggest common commonality about
their functioning and in terms of their
structure is there all of them have a
TPS domain and all of these need ATP
hydrolysis for their functioning now
let's talk about the diversity of their
mechanism of action if you follow this
chart you can understand the number of
subunits are very different in terms of
these 3 different family of nucleosome
remodeling complex they might have a
bromodomain or chroma domain that kind
of domain for interacting with the
histone modification all might not as
well for example is w1 doesn't have any
kind of promoter chroma domain now one
of the common kind of model remodeling
is like nucleosome sliding and it is
kind of performed by all these kind of
nucleosome remodeling complex but let's
say histone transfer is only performed
by swi/snf not by is tableaux and
similarly the restructuring capability
is unique to swi/snf it is not present
in MI to CH t family or is w1 family so
though there are commonality in terms of
functioning but there are some unique
properties in these kind of nucleosome
remodeling family complex families and
about this I have a detailed video later
now several in vitro experiments has
suggested that is w1 remodelers
organized nucleosome into
per bundle format and they make sure
that the spacing between the nucleosomes
are equal and the maintain the symmetry
whereas i whereas why sniff complex's
actually disorder nucleosome and both
the kind what kind of outcome has
important implications on gene
expression and transcription profile now
the is w1 family remodelers can be very
important in terms of maintenance of
higher order chromatin structure and it
turns out it maintains the compact
chromatin state after the replication is
done similarly there are other
nucleosome remodelling complex which
instead of helping gene expression might
depress the gene expression and might
lead to transcriptional repression such
as nerd complex which is an MI to CH D
family remodeling complex and it leads
to repression and it is super important
in terms of stem cell maintenance I mean
maintenance of the stem cells
pluripotent state that is why we can
understand depending upon the context
depending upon which interactors it is
interacting to nucleosome remodeling
complex can remodel that chromatin
landscape in different ways and each of
these different type of modification
have different physiological
implications that would that is super
important in context of development and
diseases I hope you enjoyed this video
this was a introductory video about
nucleosome remodeling complex in other
videos we would look in details of these
sub families and bear more of a action
and all the nuts and bolts of that so if
you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you